welcome to Hanson on the remote place on
the west coast of Canada
about ten kilometers long and two
kilometers wide this island belongs to
two groups and First Nations and the oka
for most of my life I've had the great
good fortune of living here in this
incredible environment and studying this
herbal creature and it's given me a
sense of peace in the world I want
everybody to have that same experience
[Music]
[Applause]
my name is Paul Spong and 47 years ago
I was a young scientist at the
University of British Columbia and part
of my job was to study an author in
captivity at the Vancouver Aquarium I
came to understand that authors are
acoustic creatures because they're using
sound to locate their prey to get what
they need to live from sound
it should not be penned up in concrete
tanks that deprived them of the sound
that the ocean that they were born into
ultimately that knowledge led me to
search for a place in the wild where I
could study orcas totally without
interfering with them and that search
led me to Hanson Island where I set a
poker lab to build a network of
half-a-dozen hydrophones that cover 50
square kilometers of the surrounding
area and they give us live audio so we
can track their movements often 24 hours
a day 60 60 or for me one of the
greatest experiences here is putting on
a pair of earphones and just listening
and then we have speakers in the forest
near the temps near the outhouse near
the camp kitchen all of the spaces
around here
one of the things you can't help
noticing and feeling is the sudden
inclusion of a boat of a vessel of a
propeller it's Jerry
[Applause]
[Music]
here at Orca lab we listen to untold
quantities of boat noise it's really
annoying we can always walk away from it
but whales can't with disruptive to
really patient it disrupts their ability
to hunt I think from a point of view the
welfare of the whales something that has
to be dealt with what I want to do is
develop the ability for people to get to
feel empathy for the creature since 2000
we've streamed live audio so that
anybody with computer access to the
Internet can listen to exactly what we
listen to in our lab what we're trying
to do is give people a taste of what it
is to be an author in this magnificent
environment in doing that they will come
to care and want to protect nature
I believe that if I can share what I
have experienced the world could not
peace
you
[Music]